I'll come back from lunch everybody here
to the afternoon session information I
was particularly excited to see this
talk because it actually thanks so much
so this is joint work with Naveen
Karthik at Columbia based on some past
work and some work in progress and then
Nicole said this is going to be pretty
tightly connected to yesterday's talk on
strategic classification so I'm really
excited to get the input of the computer
scientists the ml people familiar with
all right so suppose we have an
allocation problem where our goal is to
allocate better goods to agents who in
some sense or another have what we can
call higher types
[Music]
okay so we want to allocate better goods
to agents with higher types in some
sense so in a schooling example maybe we
want to give better college slots to
students who are higher ability coming
from high school in the credit market
maybe we want to loan more money or give
lower interest rates to borrowers who
are more likely to repay their loan or
maybe think of a web search example
where Google wants to give better search
results to websites that are higher
quality more relevant Amazon wants to
give better rankings to higher quality
products the problem in all of these
cases is that the agent type isn't
necessarily going to be directly
observable in particular evaluators
might only observe data that can be
manipulated by the agent so in the
schooling example let's say we're
deciding where you go to college based
on your SAT score but you can do test
prep to improve your SAT score credit
market as we heard yesterday there's a
lot of complicated things you can do
opening closing accounts adjusting the
balance in different places to improve
your FICO credit score and then in web
search you know you can do search engine
optimization to put lots of highly
searched keywords on your site for
Amazon products you can pay people to
put fake reviews on your product to make
it look better to these evaluators so
the point of this talk and I'll come at
this in a few different ways is that
when you have heterogeneity in this sort
of gaming ability so some students have
access to better test prep than others
some Amazon sellers are more willing to
hire someone to write fake reviews for
them than others are that's going to
lead to undesirable allocations from the
perspective of allocating better goods
to higher types fairness isn't the
language I would normally use for this
but that's the
the session is about and I think we can
kind of connect these two a lot of
fairness concerns when you think about
well who are the people who have access
to better test prep versus worst test
prep things like that it could correlate
with you know advantaged or
disadvantaged types that we do care
about I would just go with well so from
the perspective of that like I would
just say the undesirable allocations
from the perspective of some designer or
some objective function but I mean
really so I think I need the language
that you guys have used for this would
be I'm really looking at an accuracy
objective and we're gonna lose accuracy
due to this what have we called a
muddled information from the
heterogeneity and test prep oh so I'll
talk about the sources of this
information loss and then what we might
do to alleviate this information loss
and so all the two different papers that
this is based on both through two
different models of this the first one
that'll go through is what I call the
signaling game the Nash equilibrium
outcome the outcome without commitment
and then so I'll start with that and
then in the end of the talk I'll go into
the commitment or the Stackelberg
problem so in a signaling game think
about an allocation that's made by a
competitive market so if something like
colleges observe your SAT score and
there are a lot of colleges competing
for students so when colleges observe
your score they're going to make some
inference of the quality of your type
based on your SAT score and then you
could think of the allocation as being
determined by their belief on your
quality given your type in other words
these competitive pressures are going to
lead to an ex post optimal allocation
given the available information based on
whatever we believe that's going to map
to the allocation you get and so in this
setting we'll be able to look for the
equilibrium outcome given the
fundamentals and then ask questions like
what kinds of fundamentals lead to a
better or worse
formation for the commitment problem
think now about a designer with some
quote unquote market power so Google
gets information about the quality of
different websites and nothing says
Google has to rank the site that it
thinks is the best first Google could
rank things out of order it could choose
to highlight sites according to just
whatever it's observables are it can use
some other rule thinking about the
poverty targeting that we heard about
earlier today the government can set
rules about if you have these
observables you are eligible for the
program or not
you get this payment and it doesn't
necessarily have to be based on what we
actually believe about you we can just
commit to these arbitrary rules and so
the question of that is going to be
comparing to the signaling game the Nash
equilibrium outcome how should we
distort these rules to improve outcomes
compared to the signaling outcome so
that's the broad outlines starting to
get into the formal language a little
bit I'm gonna suppose that the agent is
going to be taking an observable action
a with a cost that depends on a two
dimensional type the two dimensions of
the type are going to be the natural
action that's what you do in the absence
of incentives that's what you do before
you manipulate and that's I'm gonna
assume the thing that the designer the
evaluator cares about we're trying to
match an allocation to your natural
action and I use the letter ADA for
natural action because it kind of looks
like the letter n the other dimension
that we don't care about directly is the
gaming ability gamma gamma is a little
bit more obvious and that's gonna index
your marginal cost of manipulation
essentially how easy for you is it to
move away from the natural action or
perhaps what are your incentives for
moving away from the natural action so
for the schooling example think about
the action as being your SAT score
natural action is how well you do after
completing high school but before doing
SAT prep and then you might have
heterogeneity and gaming ability coming
from different students who have more or
less money to pay for tutoring people
might have access to different quality
test prep material different information
about how to study or maybe some
students care a lot about getting a high
score and so they do a lot of test prep
other students don't care very much for
the web search example you know we
talked about Amazon
maybe there's heterogeneity and just
willingness to do shady stuff like
paying fake reviewers or making fake
websites that link to your own and so
forth alright so formalizing the
signaling game now we have the agent
with this two dimensional type choosing
an action at some cost and then given
the action that we observe observers can
form a belief about your natural action
which I'll call ADA hat that's the
expectation of your natural action given
the observable a agents have a benefit
they have a value in the signaling game
that all break apart as s times V of ADA
hat so s is going to be the stakes
parameter just how important is this
allocation decision how much is at stake
and then the V term says you prefer that
the market thinks that you are a higher
type you get a benefit from being
thought of as better and so your payoff
putting these two terms together is your
value S times V of ADA hat minus your
cost so a few observations about this I
started out by talking about an
allocation problem but here the
allocation is implicit we're just
looking at a value as a function of
beliefs in the background you could
think about this as when I am thought of
as a higher type people think I'm a
better student so therefore I get into a
better college but we're kind of living
that in reduced form for now when we
back to the commitment problem we're
gonna make that more explicit and then
just a comparison to the talk yesterday
on strategic classification I'm going to
assume that the value function is
continuously increasing the talk
yesterday was focusing on a binary
classification so there it would be zero
value and then jumping up to a high
value and here any extra improvement in
the belief you can get is better for you
because of that you can it's also going
to be kind of less relevant to think
about did you get exact were you
classified exactly correctly or not
you know presumably there's going to be
some error for everyone because there's
something more continuous going on in
the background all right so the only
place in the model that these two
dimensions the gaming ability and the
natural action appear is in the cost
function so describing the cost function
to you is really the heart of the model
it tells you how these two dimensions
interact and what they mean so I'm going
to go through this a little bit
carefully first let's talk about the
natural action so the natural action is
going to be your ideal point it's what
you can do at zero cost and then just
like yesterday in fact I'm also going to
assume that you can take actions below
the natural action for free so the
property we call free downward
deviations so you're taking the SAT is
it's hard to get more questions right
it's easy to get questions wrong that
you already know how to answer easy to
screw up your search results it's hard
to make them better and then the costs
are differentiable convex and higher
natural actions correspond to lower
marginal costs of increasing your action
so the blue curve is a high natural
action red curve is the costs for low
natural action and the blue curve at
every point is flatter than the red
curve
that's going to give us single crossing
in a signaling game meaning that higher
natural actions indeed correspond to
what we would call higher types in a
signaling game all right so now the
gaming ability having a higher gaming
ability yep these functions are related
to each other they received forms you
can I think the simplest way to think
about it would be that this is just
literally a shift to the right I'm not
assuming that now but yeah that's
consistent with all of this is you're
just shifting the costs to the right
higher gaming ability corresponds to
doesn't change your ideal point but it
flattens out your marginal costs so you
can think of it it's just multiplicative
if you want higher gaming ability just
shrinks your marginal costs so shrinks
your costs and then finally let's put
these two together so here's an
assumption that connects the natural
action and the gaming ability suppose we
have a pair of cross types so one type
with a higher natural action and lower
gaming ability call that the natural
type and another type with the higher
gaming ability and lower natural action
call that the gamer type and let's look
at the ratio of marginal costs for the
natural relative to the game or type I'm
going to assume that this marginal cost
ratio is strictly increasing and it
crosses one for any pair of cross types
so there's some action where to the left
of this action the blue curve the
natural type is going to be flatter than
the red curve and then to the right of
that the blue curve is steeper than the
red curve and I call this action at
which the types flip at which the slopes
flip the order of versing action because
if we're thinking about this in the
language of a signaling game the type
with the lower marginal costs is the
higher type so to the left of this
action the natural type is the high type
to the right of this the gamer type is
the high type in that sense of marginal
costs alright so now we have structure
on the problem just sort of putting
everything together in one slide higher
natural action you can think of as
shifting your curves to the right and
therefore reducing them higher gaming
ability you can think of as flattening
things out and if you want a functional
form example just think about quadratic
costs where your natural action is your
ideal point and then just divide through
by the gaming ability
okay so to complete the definition of
the signaling game now fix a joint
distribution over types and we look for
a Bayesian Nash equilibrium where the
market has some belief as a function of
your action and then agents maximize
their payoff over the choice of action
and so a first preliminary observation
to make and this is really where the
free downward deviations is coming in is
that there's actually always a fully
pooling equilibrium meaning an
equilibrium in which no information
about your type is conveyed because
there exists some equilibrium where we
all just take really low actions and if
you were to ever take a higher action
nobody would infer that you were a
higher type so nobody bothers doing that
so that's not really going to be an
interesting equilibrium for us we're
going to be interested in the
possibility of more informative
equilibria but it's sort of a warning
shot for us that reminds us look in
signaling games we generally have many
equilibria and we're gonna have to deal
with that if we want to say anything
there exists an equilibrium in which the
market does not believe you are a higher
type I'm not saying that's the right
equilibrium I'm not saying it should be
the equilibrium we think of as the
correct one just it exists as an
equilibrium
it shouldn't so again thinking of this
as a signaling game if I change my
behavior if I deviate from the
equilibrium to change my behavior I
don't actually get to change the markets
belief function so there we could think
about different equilibria where agents
tend to do this instead of that but if I
personally change my behavior the market
kind of doesn't respond it could be two
players it could be a mass of agents on
the other side it's the same game either
all right so why do we add in this
heterogeneity on the gaming ability well
if all agents had the same gaming
ability then we'd also have a perfectly
informative separating equilibrium where
observers would perfectly learn your
type from your action now again going
back to yesterday's talk this isn't
necessarily a good equilibrium from the
agents perspective because I'm a high
type the market learns that I'm a high
type but in order to learn that I had to
do 8,000 hours of test prep so I'm not
very happy but from the designers
perspective or just from the perspective
of how much information is gathered by
the market and how good do the
allocations match your types that's sort
of a good equilibrium in that sense so
the heterogeneity over the gaming
ability is going to be the source of
white there may be information loss all
right so now we can go into the first
set of main results which is that in a
variety of ways having higher stakes in
the value function leads to worse
information so I formally or novena and
I formally proved this in three
different ways and again the
complication and all of this is there
may be a very large equilibrium set so
how do we do comparisons of information
when there's multiple equilibria so we
start with the two-by-two model meaning
that the type space is low and high
natural action low and high gaming
ability so put that together you have
four types total even though there's
still a very large number of equilibria
potentially in this model we can get a
handle on it and we can show in this
case that the set of equilibria at low
stakes is less sorry is more informative
than the set of equilibria at high
stakes in the sense of the Blackwell
weak set order meaning that for any
equilibrium at high stakes we pick out
we can find a more informative
equilibrium at low stakes and for
the equilibrium at low stakes we can
find a less informative equilibrium at
high stakes we actually show this in a
perturbation 'el way we pick an
equilibrium at some level of stakes and
we can show that as you continuously
raise the stakes we can continuously
distort this equilibrium into a more and
sorry a less informative one and
vice-versa going the other way so that's
a two-by-two model it's sort of nice to
be able to show something very precisely
for the model we can actually get our
hands on but we're also of course
interested in more general distributions
and supports so for the fully general
model we can talk about limiting results
as the stakes get very low people
approximately just take their natural
action and so we get approximately full
information as the stakes get high we
don't actually necessarily approach no
information because we if the two
dimensions of the type are correlated
with each other we might learn something
about your natural action from your
gaming ability so suppose that these two
dimensions are positively correlated
well at really high stakes
it's the types with the high gaming
ability that can take really high
actions at the lowest cost but if those
types tend to be the ones that have high
natural actions as well then we'll get
some information from this but if the
types are independent then you do in
fact at a non informative equilibrium so
there's sort of a limit on how much
information you get based on what you
can infer from the gaming ability and
then finally we have some parametric
results for a linear quadratic
elliptical model so linear value
function quadratic costs and then
elliptical a joint elliptical
distribution for the agents types so an
elliptical distribution is a
generalization of a normal distribution
that allows for things like compact
support which is often nice in this
setting when you
linear quadratic elliptical we actually
get linear equilibria where everything
can be very well described in the
language of linear regressions in
particular we can characterize the
amount of information the market gets by
the r-squared of regressing your natural
action on the observed action so just
how informative is the observable about
the dimension we care about we look at
the r-squared of that regression and in
this linear equilibrium as the stakes
get higher the R squared goes down so in
a few different ways showing this kind
of general theme that higher stakes lead
to worse information and you can think
about this as one formalization of what
was called good hearts law yesterday
information quality gets better the less
we actually use the information because
higher incentives mean more incentives
to manipulate which lead to more
manipulation and therefore worse
information and one thing I want to
highlight here is that kind of this
structure of the model is really
important in getting this result if we
had actually flipped things and said
suppose that we care about the thing
that I call the gaming ability and we
don't care about the natural action
because I actually want to know how hard
people work and that might be
characterized by the gaming ability all
of these results would flip you'd get
more information not less information at
higher stakes so it's not like a general
principle that higher incentives to
manipulate necessarily lead to
information loss it's something that you
really need to come out of the structure
of the model okay so now that we know
one source of information loss we can
think about what interventions might you
do to try to improve information and the
first one's kind of obvious I just told
you that higher stakes lead to worse
information so what can we do to reduce
stakes here is something we can do
think about the credit market so your
credit score is obviously used for loan
applications
but it turns out it's also used for a
bunch of other things more commonly in
recent years so when you apply for
certain kinds of jobs they do a credit
check where the implication for the
employers inference is that if you get a
have a higher credit score you're
probably a more reliable person in
general we can trust you you'll come
into work on time you won't steal from
us my guess is these things don't really
have data behind them but employers
believe it for insurance markets they
actually have a lot of data behind it it
turns out that in auto insurance if you
have a higher credit score you are less
likely to file an auto insurance claim I
don't think the insurance companies know
exactly why this is true but they don't
really care this is more data they can
plug in to their underwriting model and
so one way of written oh sorry but I
believe that like some of that comes
from like people with high credit scores
living a low crime areas I I don't know
the answer to that yeah I think one
reason why FICO scores are often used is
that you kind of have like if you try to
do your own data analysis you might get
dinged for disparate impact whatever and
there seems to be like a general general
acceptance that the FICO score is sort
of pre-cleared that that passes certain
rules certainly in lending markets like
if you try to do your own underwriting
of lending like you don't have to worry
if you using the FICO score and you do
have to worry about lawsuits if you're
doing something else but yeah I don't
know the data behind this and honestly
I'm not sure the insurance companies
know or maybe they intentionally don't
know because they're worried what they
might find alright so here's an
intervention if we pass a law that says
you're
not allowed to use credit information
for insurance or employment well you
have now lowered the stakes on people
trying to raise their credit score which
is going to mean that you're going to
improve the information in the credit
market and of course there are a lot of
other people arguing for more explicit
fairness based reasons that maybe we
shouldn't be allowed to use credit
scores for employment it's not fair that
because you missed a bill a payment on a
bill now you can't get a job and again
this is sort of a complementary or a
separate argument for why this might
have some beneficial effects another
thing you could do to improve
information is try to make the mechanism
harder to manipulate in some sense what
do I mean by harder to manipulate well
in math I said the agent is maximizing
stakes x value minus cost mathematically
this is the same as the agent maximizing
let's just divide through by s value
minus cost divided by s so the stakes s
can also be thought as parametrizing
manipulation costs higher stakes higher
s uniformly reduces costs of
manipulation making it easier for people
to manipulate so how might we make a
mechanism harder to manipulate one thing
we can do is we can base it on different
kinds of data so certain test questions
might be easier to study for or harder
to study for if you think about like web
search if you're doing search based on
the keywords on a site itself that's
gonna be pretty easy to manipulate
because I get to choose what words are
on my own site if you're doing something
like page rank or analysis of incoming
links that's gonna be harder for me to
manipulate because it's based on what
other people are saying about me so
that's the one kind of thing that could
improve information another thing also
referenced yesterday was that you can
obscure the details of the algorithm to
make it harder to manipulate and so very
explicitly fair Isaac
operation which does credit score's and
Google you know come out and say we
don't want to give too much detail about
how these algorithms work because we
don't want to make them easier to game
the college board as well which runs the
SAT tests prior to the 1970s at a policy
where they wouldn't reveal old test
questions I think at the time they
claimed that you can't study for the SAT
it's a test that is you know study proof
but maybe just in case we're also not
revealing the old test questions now I
just said that making a mechanism more
obscure or less transparent could be
good for information but now you have
the college board going in the other way
by the 1980s they started selling books
of old test questions today they now
actually don't just release material
that you can use for test prep they
actually run their own test prep so
they've partnered with the Khan Academy
to have free videos for people to
prepare for the SATs and again these are
free videos they're not trying to make
money off it so why if I just said that
transparency is bad why might they now
be interested in transparency well
here's some background that might
explain what's going on by the mid 70s
or so Kaplan had started advertising
that if you take our test prep classes
you can improve your SAT score by an
average of a hundred points and one of
the things that Kaplan had done to
improve their test prep quality was they
would throw parties for students after
they take the SATs and then ask the
students do you remember any questions
from the test can you write them down
for us so at this point you know by the
70s SAT test prep had become a big
business and so you could think that
well some people effectively already
have access to these old test questions
by giving access to everyone you're
really kind of leveling the playing
field and when they started partnering
with the
Khan Academy they used that language
explicitly they want to level the
playing field by making truly
world-class test prep material freely
available to all students where right
now the rich students get it and the
poor students don't let's make it freely
available so everyone gets it and this
goes back to the point that information
loss is driven by heterogeneity and
gaming ability so if by making a
mechanism more transparent you aren't
uniformly making it easier for everyone
to manipulate if what you're doing is
raising the people for whom manipulation
was harder and raising them up to the
level of the others that could be a
source for how transparency improves
rather than harms 'men information all
right now let's shift gears to the
commitment problem if you have a
designer behind all of this Google
Amazon maybe for poverty targeting the
government gets to set what the rules
are and doesn't have to worry about
outside competition then now we can
potentially commit to an arbitrary
mapping of action to a location that's
not necessarily based on the inferred
beliefs so the question here is how do
we distort the signaling equilibrium to
improve information again just to remind
ourselves with the explicit goal of
improving accuracy the conclusion that
I'm gonna argue for is that what you
want to do is you want to flatten the
allocation rule in other words you want
to commit to putting less weight on the
manipulable data now you might notice
that even though I'm looking at accuracy
I have a lot of questions about this if
we commit to flattening the allocation
rule you're reducing the incentives to
manipulate so that's actually going to
help lower signaling costs as well
lowering the burden of what was called
the social burden in yesterday's talk
but that's just a side benefit here I'm
kind of focusing on accuracy all right
so let's go through the model now and
how do I argue for this what do I mean
by this in a formal sense so now I have
to be more explicit about the designer
side of the problem because now the
designer is maximizing something so
again you have agents with this two
dimensional type natural action gaming
ability and suppose that the designer
wants to match the agents allocation
I'll call it y to the natural action ADA
and let's just give the designer or
quadratic loss utility and the designer
is going to set an allocation based on
an observable X and I've switched the
notation here but the observable X is
exactly just taking the role of the
action from the signaling game but now
kind of in more regression e-language
and so a couple big assumptions first
I'm just going to restrict attention to
linear allocation rules so Y of X equals
beta times X plus beta naught and so
this beta term is going to describe the
level of the incent incentives how
sensitive the allocation is to the
observable and then the agent is going
to choose the observable for action X
based on our type and also we'll adjust
it in response to the allocation rule
and I'm going to again make a simple
assumption on the functional forms I'm
going to suppose that the agent chooses
a one-dimensional action X equal to ADA
plus gamma times beta so as before ADA
is the natural action that's what I do
in the absence of
incentives beta is the strength of
incentives and then gamma is your gaming
ability so with no incentives I just
take my natural action then as either
the incentives get higher or as my own
gaming ability goes up I adjust my
action further away from my natural
action and this functional form is not
arbitrary this is exactly what we get if
we had linear value and quadratic costs
and just let me highlight this again
we're choosing a continuous allocation Y
and the agent value is being a little
bit higher so there's no step function
here it's sort of harder to think about
what it would even mean to flatten a
step function because a step function is
very steep whether it's here or whether
it's here but for a linear policy it
makes a lot of sense to talk about
flattening it's just using a smaller
coefficient than that if you have time
at the end I have some thoughts on what
it mean might mean to flatten in other
kinds of models but it's all very hand
wavy all right so some preliminaries
suppose that I set some allocation rule
with sensitivity beta tilde and then I
gather data on what's the Joint
Distribution in the data between the
type of that I care about and the agents
action X so we could run a linear
regression and let's call a de hat my
best guess of a de from this linear
regression that I run holding the agents
behavior as fixed in response to this
policy so beta hat of beta tilde
describes the coefficient on from the
linear regression when the agent is
responding to the policy beta tilde so
there's a very convenient decomposition
of the welfare loss now
the designers welfare loss which is just
quadratic loss can be decomposed into
two terms the first term says how well
does my linear regression actually
predict the agents type forget about
what I'm doing with this information
just how much information is there in
the world how much can I infer about
your type from your observables and then
separately what am I doing with this
information am i giving you the
allocation that I think is right given
what I can infer from the data or am i
distorting it away from what I think is
right so we have the information loss of
estimation plus the missile location
loss given the estimation the linear
regression I'm thinking about is
regressing there type on the data so you
would need to gather information about
their type in order to do this
regression yeah you're saying I'm not
saying it has to be and I think let's
talk later about what else you could do
in a nonlinear model I'm just for
tractability for now in order to have
something to prove I'm just restricting
to linear regression for now but let's
talk later about that
all right so this is the designers best
guess of your type given that you are
responding to some fixed policy and now
you could think about the designers best
response if I thought that the agent's
behavior would stay the same then the
policy I should choose is exactly just
set the allocation equal to my best
guess of your type the problem is that
if I do that then the agent's behavior
is going to change so here is a graph of
beta hat as a function of beta this is
the coefficient in the linear regression
if if we had no incentives at all then
we would get a coefficient of 1 in the
regression but the more incentives we
give the higher we make beta the more
agent manipulation we're going to get
which means that the linear regression
we run is going to be based on noisier
and noisier data so it's going to have a
lower coefficient on X when the agent is
manipulating more and in the welfare
loss decomposition that's going to have
a larger information loss of estimation
as you raise beta the information loss
of estimation goes up now you could
think about solving for the fixed point
as follows the fixed point is just going
to be the intersection of this
decreasing beta hat curve with the beta
hat equals beta curve just the y equals
x line that's gonna be the point for
which if I gather data I best respond to
that gather more data update my policy
gather more data best respond and so
forth if you iterate that forever then
eventually where you land where you are
best responding to the policy that you
have in fact set that's the what I call
the fix point policy that's going to
have a coefficient right there and when
we look at this welfare loss
decomposition
because I am best responding to what the
agent does there is no misallocation
loss given estimation but there may be a
large information loss of estimation but
given the information I have I am doing
exactly the right thing that's what it
means to be the fixed-point the designer
is best responding so now let's think
about starting from this fixed point
policy what if you started reducing the
incentives a little bit you reduced beta
in the allocation rule y equals beta
times X plus a constant
well you would get a first-order benefit
from reducing the information loss of
estimation because the agent is going to
be manipulating less in response to
weaker incentives so more informative
observables now there's gonna be some
miss allocation loss that you're adding
but because you're starting from a
minimum because you're starting from
zero miss allocation loss that's only
going to be a second-order loss
so we could say immediately that there's
going to be a first-order benefit of
reducing beta from the fixed point value
so that's the intuition for the result
that the optimal policy in fact does
have a coefficient you commit to of beta
less than the fixed point value the
actual proof is a bit more complicated
you need to you know show that not only
is there a local maximum below the fixed
point level but also that it's the
global Max and this is a quartic so it
ends up being a little bit complicated
but we can show that so this is the
formalization of the result I promised
that we improve information by
flattening the allocation rule or
putting less weight on the manipulable
predictor and so the question that one
of you raised earlier was okay that's a
linear model how do we even think about
nonlinear models what does it even mean
to flatten an allocation rule when I'm
not using a linear policy but maybe I'm
doing something instead like I have a
manipulable data source and also 50
other pieces of data that I'm using to
fit some complicated machine
model and then I'm going to deliver you
an allocation based on the prediction
from this machine learning model what
does it mean to flatten the allocation
rule with respect to one particular
input and so we have some thoughts about
this the main one is that it seems like
we could get in that direction by
running a machine learning prediction
where we've artificially added noise to
the manipulable component in the
estimation that should make the
regression or the prediction less
sensitive to the value of this component
in a linear regression you can formalize
that that's just the familiar
attenuation bias from simple linear
regression that if you have noisy
estimate of an X you get a lower
regression coefficient and it seems like
you know I don't know machine learning
maybe you guys can tell me about the
connections here it seems like the same
idea should maybe improve would be a way
of improving information from a
manipulate here this seems like it adds
an additional microeconomic we found in
Jason might like regularization and
lasso type of models which seem to limit
the size of beta and people like that
for other reasons but this is like a
theory of almost the optimality of last
seven regularization what do you think I
think I should defer on that question
that sounds plausible i we should talk
more about it or maybe we should talk
more about it I'd love to hear more
about kind of the connections this might
have to other you know ideas and machine
learning but
yeah I don't have an answer for you that
are you are so your your value was
always like you know I get more by being
a little bit higher I guess this slide
was supposed to help me understand what
would happen in Brianna stop function
okay so here's so here's think about
here's kind of a way of thinking about a
step function imagine that we have not
one dimension of information but suppose
there's one manipulable component and
then there's also some other information
we have so they're even in like a linear
model or not quite linear but
so a step function of something like X 1
plus alpha times X 2 if this is the
manipulable component you can sort of
flatten the allocation with respect to
this component by reducing the
coefficient alpha even though you're
still using a step function because it's
a smaller coefficient on this relative
to the other one and I think that's
essentially what you would get if you
estimated with adding noise
[Applause]